DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today, my guest is
Louis Gray, my friend
and colleague from Google.
We had a great show last week,
and I invited him back again
this week to go deeper
on luck and timing
and what it takes to
succeed as a startup.
Welcome, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks for
having me on again, Don.
Appreciate it.
DON DODGE: Yeah.
So we got into it a little bit
last week about luck and timing
and how that plays into success.
We've both been in startups
where we worked hard,
we had a great idea, we
did the best we could,
and for various
reasons, it didn't work.
How big of a part do you
think luck and timing
played in some of those and
some of the ones I've done?
LOUIS GRAY: I think luck and
timing are significant factors.
One thing about any
kind of business
is you're not in a vacuum.
If you're starting a
business in a place
has absolutely no
competition, you have to stop
and think, say, maybe I'm
not in a market at all.
Maybe I'm deluding myself.
Usually, you enter a market that
has significant competitors,
probably two, three,
five strong ones.
You have to find out what it
is that differentiates you.
What is the market that you
can go after first where
you have the highest
chance of success,
and what do you need to do to
adapt your story as you try
and broaden that market?
When you look at timing, there's
also a lot of other factors
which you have absolutely
no control over at all.
One company I was with, I
joined the company in '01.
We launched our first
product in July of 2001,
and the morning
of September 11, I
was supposed to host a webinar
with hundreds and hundreds
of attendees talking about
our latest and greatest.
As you can imagine,
that webinar didn't
happen because of other
factors, and the resulting
economic crises that happened
afterwards and people's lack
of willingness to
take more of a risk
and go to things that are more
entrenched and more secure
really impacted us as a company
and impacted our ability
to be successful.
And you don't have
control over that.
What you do have control over
is what you have to offer,
what you bring to the table,
how much attention you
pay to the rest of the market.
What are the adjustments
that you need to make?
How are your
customers responding
to what it is that you offer?
And what are your
competitors doing well
that you could possibly
learn from and do better?
DON DODGE: So
timing does matter.
In the case of that example
you use, September 11,
that was a big
catastrophe, and no one
could have predicted that.
But there are other things
that you can predict.
So give me another example
of where timing mattered.
Let's talk about
Twitter and Ev Williams.
So we always say teams
make the difference,
but there are many
examples where
a really smart team,
experienced, tried something,
failed, pivoted, failed, and
then did something that--
LOUIS GRAY: I think
you and I both know
some of the players
on that team,
but we're not intimately
familiar with everything
about that team.
We start to learn more
as we read those stories
and talk to people about it.
If you look at the
origins of Twitter,
it came out of Odeo, which
originally was a podcasting
company making
podcasting software.
And when Apple integrated
podcasting directly
into iTunes, their market
essentially vanished overnight.
And they came up with a
number of different ideas
to try and keep that
company going, one of which
was this status
update called Twitter
that Jack Dorsey and
others had come up with.
And we all know what's
happened in the ensuing years.
It really took off beyond
anybody's imagination
as far as we could see.
And it's really
interesting to see
how they came to that
conclusion out of a company that
was in dire straits.
And I think sometimes
when I talk about timing,
sometimes companies and
products are ahead of the market
where the market
doesn't exist yet,
but they had a brilliant idea.
Now, one of the examples I give
often is from Sun Microsystems,
and Sun now is a little
bit of a dinosaur.
It's gone back in time 10
years ago, 20 years ago,
they were huge.
And now in the
valley, they're almost
like an afterthought
in a Wikipedia entry.
But they had a product
called Sun Ray,
and Sun Ray basically was a
web-based operating system
where you could plug in and
get all your content directly
from the main server, but have
nothing on your local drive.
And when they originally came
out, it just didn't work,
and there were issues with
broadband capability, people
not wanting to give
up the content they
have on a local
operating system.
But now you see
something like Chrome OS,
which I use every single day,
where it just makes sense.
I can't fathom running
applications locally
and having files locally anymore
because the cloud has grown up,
and web internet, the
speeds of the internet
have grown up so much as well.
DON DODGE: That is
an excellent example.
I remember working on
a network computer.
Larry Ellison and Oracle came
up with this idea of a network
computer, and this
was back in '97, '98,
which is exactly what
the Chromebook is today.
So same idea, but the timing
was wrong with the NC,
and it's right with Chrome.
LOUIS GRAY: You're
talking about 1998,
and that was when
the iMac came out.
And I remember hearing
rumors that if you held down
the N key, it would boot up and
say, "Welcome to the Mac NC."
And the original
idea was that it
was supposed to have been
a network-based computer,
and then at the
last minute, they
threw in a four gig
hard drive, and it all
went off to where it is today.
But timing is a huge deal.
I look at some of the work
that we did at BlueArc.
The first years I
was there, we were
selling devices that
were exceptionally fast,
things that were perfect for
post-production and geophysics
and bioinformatics.
But it wasn't honed enough that
you could put it in a core data
IT center, and so
I would see people
who weren't willing
to take that risk.
But if we had been maybe either
more developed and more fully
on board by the
time we launched,
or if we had probably
launched two years earlier,
we could have been
something dramatic.
Our timing was just
off based on what
we delivered versus what the
market wanted at the time.
DON DODGE: So another example
of timing that I use often
is Angry Birds.
Angry Birds was the 52nd
game that this team built.
So same team, same general
concepts, but the 52nd try
was a blockbuster
billion dollar hit.
LOUIS GRAY: Which
everybody knows
and everybody's played
a million times.
That's a really cool thing.
I've met Mr. Angry Bird himself.
I remember seeing him
at Google I/O in 2011,
always wearing the
great outfit, and I
know our colleague Martin
Omander has met him
several times.
But it's a really
interesting story
to see you go from we're trying,
we're trying, we're trying,
and we're not giving
up, into something
that looks like an
overnight success
because nobody was watching
their first 51 tries.
I know just before
the show, you and I
were talking about
some well known names
in the Valley like
Marissa Mayer.
Marissa is now CEO at Yahoo
and had an incredible career
here at Google.
And you look at her story.
How did she join
Google and become
the first female engineer?
They were talking about
her having upwards of 15
or 30 different job
opportunities ahead of her,
and she could have selected
something else with less risk.
She could have gone ahead and
picked a consulting company
and probably done exceptionally
well, knowing her work ethic,
but she wouldn't have had the
transformative career that she
had at Google and
now at Yahoo as well.
You look at Steve Jobs
and Steve Wozniak.
They both had interesting
careers at HP and Atari
developing Breakout, and they
could have just stayed there
and been comfortable.
But instead, they wanted
to change the world,
and went off and started Apple.
And just a really interesting
scenario of taking a risk,
and also finding the
right time to do it.
DON DODGE: So in summary,
then, be really smart,
work really hard, and
make the timing right.
That's the--
LOUIS GRAY: Make the
timing right, and the way
you make the timing right is
paying attention to the way
the customers are responding
to you, the way the partners
and the other stakeholders
are responding to you,
seeing what's happening
in the market.
It was not the right time to
launch the network computer
in 1997.
I believe the right time is now,
or two years ago when I first
got my first CR48.
The ability to do
what you can do today
in an always connected
world is much different
than it was 15 years ago.
DON DODGE: Louis,
this is awesome.
Great show.
And I think maybe we can
come back again and talk
about why now, because when
investors look at startups,
they hear the pitch and
they look at the team
and they see everything, but
to get to the timing question,
they say, why now?
And as a startup
entrepreneur, if you
can't answer that
question, why now, then
maybe you ought to wait.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
I think before we go, one last
thing I want to talk about.
When you hit Twitter,
would they ever
have succeeded without
the massive penetration
of mobile and smartphones?
I think if they had just
been a website, just
another flat website,
they would never seen
the stratospheric
growth that they've had.
And it all started with
mobile and the ability
to consume the content
right there on your phone
and update immediately
on your phone.
And mobile has
changed everything.
DON DODGE: I think you're right.
Well, thank you very
much for joining us,
and join us next
time when we get
into another topic
of great interest.
Before we leave, I'd like to
remind you of a special offer
that we have for Root Access
viewers, the $2,000 Google
Cloud credit.
So if you're developing
applications on the cloud,
try Google Cloud and
get a $2,000 credit.
Thank you very much for joining
us and see you next time.